for diego calliso the five years he
spent looking for a job and the future
were the most miserable when the crisis
hit spain he decided to move and look
elsewhere i was looking for a job
begging for a job please give me a job
etc etc i feel really bad how can you
realize what you want to do or be
productive if society is telling you all
the time without the job you are useful
across europe five and a half million
young people are struggling to find
their way into the job market in spain
57 of people under 25 are out of work
young people is not seeing any kind of
hope also the people who has employment
here has really a precarious situation
we have to stop with the austerity and
really invest in what is really working
otherwise we will have uh divided europe
fears echoed by many meps particularly
those trying to steer european policy
away from austerity towards
interventions that they believe will
lead to growth and jobs there's a lot at
stake what we are seeing is the last
generation the most qualified people
ever
doesn't have any sign of future
and that means a lot i think if young
people don't have a future the european
project might not have a future as well
this thursday and friday heads of member
states will meet to discuss the keys to
unlocking the economic crisis youth
unemployment is top of the agenda
governments have put six billion on the
table but meps think it's not enough a
positive
different wisdom emerges from the street
one born of depression the self-help
model i don't think that we need to wait
for politicians to create europe just do
something and maybe the politicians are
gonna follow you are gonna follow the
people what we create